also wir schauen auf das live bild oben
rechts im kleinen kästchen
wir warten immer noch darauf dass ist
bewegung im zuschauerraum und das soll
wirklich gleich losgehen paul ronzheimer
ist hier der aus der sitzung heraushört
dass es einerseits durchaus auch
reibereien noch gibt andererseits haben
wir auch gehört dass durchaus auch ja
ein bisschen lockere stimmung herrscht
ganz
nette situationen die sich da zwischen
dem thüringischen ministerpräsidenten
ramelow und dem
altkanzler olaf scholz und frau merkel
abgespielt hat als es darum ging welche
einschränkungen denn nun verkündet
werden sollte sagte ramelow was gilt
denn dann bei trauerfeiern und was gilt
denn zum beispiel beim abschied nehmen
daraufhin gab es eine kurzes schweigen
im raum und dann lächelte scholz merkel
an und sagte zapfenstreich absagen
merkel lächelte zurück und tschentscher
der erste bürgermeister von hamburg
peter tschentscher sagte das ist fies
hintergrund da natürlich dass angela
merkel heute abend von der bundeswehr
beim großen zapfenstreich verabschiedet
wird also eine mischung sozusagen aus
anspannung und dann ein bisschen lösen
diese anspannung ja es war ungewöhnlich
dass olaf scholz scherze macht ja der
ist sehr ernst aber tatsächlich in
sitzung wenn jetzt nicht die kamera auf
ihn gerichtet ist kann er auch durchaus
mal ein bisschen locker sein wie da
denkt man gar nicht ist aber tatsächlich
so was die situation dort gezeigt hat
ist dass viele auch nicht so genau
wissen in welche richtung man jetzt
gehen sollte zumindest bei den
ministerpräsidenten scheint da die
unsicherheit groß zu sein ob das jetzt
reicht also michael kretschmer hat
mehrfach gesagt man bräuchte alles also
auch die möglichkeit weiterer größerer
schließungen die möglich sind und andere
ministerpräsident verweisen darauf dass
man auch erst mal schauen ob die zahlen
wirken denn die hospitalisierung rate im
ganzen land beziehungsweise die inzidenz
rate ja durchaus abflacht momentan kann
ich mal auf die beschlussvorlage
das was wir wissen was also heute morgen
sozusagen schon vorlag als man gegen 11
uhr in diese
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz
hineingegangen ist das ist hier nämlich
der neue corona plan so soll er gleich
verkündet werden restaurants theater und
kinos soll nur für geimpfte und genesene
öffnen genauso wie der einzelhandel nur
noch mit 2 gb betretbar sein soll daran
davon ausgeschlossen sind natürlich die
supermärkte damit man sich eben noch
versorgen kann maximal 10.000 personen
sollen bei großveranstaltungen noch
erlaubt sein da war heute noch nicht
ganz klar ob es vielleicht zehn
vielleicht aber auch 15.000 personen
sein sollen da werden wir gleich nochmal
genaueres zu hören und wir haben darüber
ja schon viel gesprochen und ist soll
jetzt kommen die impfpflicht erst für
pflegerinnen und pfleger und dann auch
für uns alle hier in deutschland
außerdem soll man nach neun monaten nach
der impfung den impfstatus verlieren
spricht man muss also entweder zur
booster impfung gehen oder man geht dann
eben nicht mehr offiziell als geimpft
oder apotheker und zahnärzte dürfen
immerhin mit impfen so dass es dann auch
wenigstens etwas schneller gehen soll
außerdem soll die masken pflicht in
allen schulen gelten und das ganze soll
jetzt
generalstabsmäßig sozusagen gehandelt
werden der krisenstab wird geleitet von
einem general major der bundeswehr
carsten bräuer sozusagen nach
italienischem vorbild wo das so
gehandelt wurde und wo man erfolge hatte
für mich klingt das alles ein bisschen
sehr nach pr-mann lenkt davon ab dass
die situation eben schlecht ist oder
will aktionistisch sozusagen jetzt
zeigen wir machen alles anders ich finde
man hat ja und das ist das interessante
bereits im winter einen impf
beauftragten zum beispiel eingesetzt der
wurde von olaf scholz eingesetzt
wohlgemerkt der das ganze logistisch
handeln sollte und dann frage ich mich
was hat er eigentlich gemacht in den
letzten monaten denn gerade die logistik
ist ja ein problem und wenn wir hören
dass peter tschentscher der heute zum
beispiel noch mal einer sitzung gesagt
hat der hamburger bürgermeister wo ist
denn der impfstoff wenn der angeblich da
sein soll es gibt zu wenig wir haben zu
wenig in frankfurt auch nicht auf dann
fragt man sich wirklich was hat denn der
impfstoff beauftragte den olaf scholz
gemacht hat den vergangenen monaten
getan um jetzt mal auch die situation
oder die verantwortlichkeit nicht
ausschließlich beim gesundheitsminister
zu sehen da jetzt ja täglich verprügelt
wird von der spd aber auch von seinen
parteikollegen von der csu von markus
söder der in so richtig auf dem kieker
hat ihren sparen bereits schon seit
monaten kann man sagen seit beginn
eigentlich der impfstoff verteilung im
januar ist hart mit ihm ins gericht
gegangen und ich denke da wird sich
jetzt olaf scholz tatsächlich messen
lassen müssen das ist seine erste große
probe das ist seine erste große große
aufgabe als kanzler er sagt boostern bis
zu 30 millionen bis zum ende des jahres
wenn die zahl weit darunter liegen
sollte dann ist es seine verantwortung
da kann man nicht mehr sagen man stelle
einsparen und er hat alles falsch
gemacht das ist jetzt die wichtigste
aufgabe für urlaubs war will olaf scholz
vielleicht jetzt auch die bundeswehr so
ein bisschen mit vorschicken weil eben
diese knapp über 30 prozent der
ungeimpften hier in deutschland
vielleicht den politikern auch einfach
nicht mehr vertrauen jetzt kann man
wenigstens sagen jetzt sind die
bundeswehr das in die hand vielleicht
vertrauen sie den mehr ich glaube die
tatsache ist man die bundeswehr einnimmt
sorgt jetzt nicht dafür dass diejenigen
die nicht geimpft sind größeres
vertrauen haben ganz im gegenteil ich
glaube da hat man so ein bisschen das
gefühl jetzt werden die fahnenflüchtigen
eingesammelt kranken und müssen müssen
die im kern also ich glaube wenn man
darauf gesetzt hätte dann ist es eher so
zu sagen in dem telegramm gruppen
wahrscheinlich jetzt nimmt der general
weil er wirklich da uns sagen will ich
denke dass das eher um tatsächlich eine
organisation ist organisatorische frage
ist ja also wie schafft man es
logistisch tatsächlich an jedem morgen
an verschiedenen apotheken in
verschiedene impfzentren genügend
impfstoff zu haben was bislang nicht
funktioniert hat und da ist generell
brown ein großer experte und nimmt sich
dieses themas jetzt an sicherlich eine
gute eine gute idee aber
schauen wir ob es auch klappt
riesige herausforderung ehrgeiziges ziel
das man sich ja gesetzt hatte olaf
scholz hat gesagt 30 millionen menschen
sollen noch geimpft werden nach geimpft
werden oder neugier und werden bis
weihnachten da sind 22 tage da sind also
weit über eine million die pro tag
geimpft werden müssten ich glaube
gestern sind 800.000 das ist schon hoch
gegangen aber trotzdem ein ziel das
eigentlich realistischerweise kaum zu
erreichen sein wird ja wir linken weit
drunter in der impfquote also gab tage
wo wir glaube ich 200.000 300.000 gerade
mal geimpft haben wie das so schnell
hoch gehen soll schauen wir mal dann
hast du so wichtig was also viel wiegt
sich nach land auch dieser druck eben
zweig
bewegt vielleicht auch einige dazu sich
impfen zu lassen absolut ich glaube
natürlich die tatsache dass man da nicht
mehr ins restaurant kann dass man nicht
mehr in die bar kann dass das sicherlich
einige bewegen wird ein bestimmter
harter kern denke ich aber wird übrig
bleiben der sozusagen da nicht belehrbar
ist und wir haben es gerade auch noch
verkündet außerdem soll gleich das
böllerverbot verkündet werden an
silvester warum kannst du noch einmal
erklären warum machen die politiker das
war henrik hat ja gerade auch noch mal
gesagt berlin ist ja er hat ja mit der
krone partie eigentlich nichts zu tun es
geht da denke ich um sozusagen
symbolpolitik um zu zeigen wir nehmen
das wahnsinnig ernst und silvester keine
party ist nicht die ist nicht jenes
keine versammlung unter klingt so was
wie böllerverbot irgendwie sinnvoll das
egal westen noch ein bisschen hin aber
ist ja nur noch ein monat also
monat von daher ist es so dass man
natürlich zeigen will nachdem auch diese
dinge passiert sind da im stadion von
köln wo noch vor wenigen tagen vor einer
woche über 50.000 im stadion saßen dass
man dort dem etwas entgegensetzen
stichwort bundeswehr stichwort corona
stichwort regierung das kommt alles
zusammen heute abend auch im großen
zapfenstreich für die bundeskanzlerin
wenn die bundeswehr ihr zu ehren die
lieblingslieder spielt unter anderem
die sie ausgewählt hat ganz interessante
auswahl die man hier eigentlich so gar
nicht zugetraut hätte wir übertragen
live ab 19 uhr hierüber bild live unter
anderem ein song von nina hagen der punk
sängerin wenn man so will aus dem jahr
1974 du hast den farbfilm vergessen
ganz bekanntes lied wir haben schon die
proben gehört und dann hildegard knef
dich solls euro für mich soll's rote
rosen regnen
ich versuche gerade vorzustellen wie
angela merkel da steht dann heute abend
und für mich soll's rote rosen regnen
erklingt dann das dass
ich hab noch nie musik gehört mit der
kanzlerin von daher kannte ich im
musikgeschmack auch nicht aber warum
nicht rea in dieser zeit ich will
natürlich darauf hinaus wir reden über
ein corona erbe das sie ihre regierungen
natürlich auch hinterlässt und er will
jetzt eine die ganzen 16 jahre mal sehen
und sie verabschiedete sich da und soll
rote rosen für sie recht ich finde da
darf man nicht so hart sein nach 16
jahren bleibt ja nicht nur die korona
krise sondern die kanzlerin als mensch
als politikerin die sich ohne zweifel
wirklich jeden tag für dieses land
eingesetzt hat man kann ihr fehler
vorwerfen man kann hier in allen
möglichen bereichen fehler vorwerfen und
sagen was nicht geklappt hat aber jetzt
zu sagen die korona krise ist so
dramatisch deswegen müsste sie jetzt
ihren musikgeschmack anpassen finde ich
irgendwie ein bisschen zuviel großer
gott wir loben dich kommt auch nur genau
von daher ist das dann vielleicht der
versöhnliche abschluss wie besonders ist
so ein abend für die ganze politik welt
ist schon ein besonderer abend zu sehen
wie die kanzlerin nach 16 jahren und als
erste kanzlerin ja freiwillig aus dem
amt scheidet möglicherweise wenn sie
sich noch mal aufgestellt hätte hätte
sie es noch mal schaffen können und sie
hat sich das ziel gesetzt noch mal
schaffen können ja ich glaube schon ich
glaube schon jetzt nochmal schaffen
können wenn man sich die umfragewerte
alleine anschauen ja also wenn man sich
anschauen wo die cdu mit ihr stand wo
die union mit ihrem stand für ihre
persönlichen beliebtheitswerte natürlich
ist es jetzt eine hätte könnte würde
frage aber ich glaube auch für über die
oder wir sprechen über die krone krise
die ministerpräsidenten frenz man muss
sich die werte anschauen die bürger die
aller große mehrheit stand immer hinter
den kurs der kanzlerin hinter ihrem
corona kurs wenn es die wahl nicht
gegeben hätte die bundestagswahl wenn
ihr sozusagen ihre macht noch weiter so
gewesen wäre wie vor anderthalb jahren
sagen niemals kinder corona krise hätte
sie wahrscheinlich versucht direkt
härtere maßnahmen durchzusetzen und
viele bürgerinnen und bürger standen
oder stehen hinter dem kurs der
kanzlerin im gegensatz zu dem zum
beispiel wie sie armin laschet lange
zeit beobachtet haben aber auch für die
spd in den vergangenen wochen bei der
korona krise gehandelt hat das sind die
werte sehr nach unten gegangen was das
vertrauen in die regierung angeht weil
man ja gesagt hat okay die epidemische
lage endet dann muss enden wir machen es
anders da musste man das gesetz
nachbessern dann wurde man überrascht
von der situation von den hohen zahlen
und ich glaube auch deswegen hat olaf
scholz jetzt so reagiert wie er reagiert
hat deswegen hat er sich für die
allgemeine impfpflicht ausgesprochen
deswegen versucht er jetzt als
handelnder aufzutreten als kanzler der
anpackt als kanzler der macht und der
jetzt dann auch diese entscheidung durch
bringen